and in the future and we will be
encouraging more countries to join us
this is the moment for ukraine's friends
to create a coalition of humanitarian
economic and defensive military support
to ensure that putin fails and that's
why today i'm announcing a further
175 million pounds of uk aid for ukraine
100 million dollars of which will be
provided directly to the ukrainian
government
this brings the total uk support
announced during this crisis to around
400 million pounds
after 12 days it's already clear that
putin has made a miscalculation
he has underestimated the ukrainians
their heroic resistance he's
underestimated their leader
and he has underestimated the unity of
the west and we will continue as
colleagues to do everything we can to
strengthen that unity in the days ahead
to ensure that putin fails in this
catastrophic invasion of ukraine thank
you very much
thank you prime minister johnson for
hosting it's great to be joined here by
uh prime minister hute as well it's been
a very productive first day of my trip
to europe we've been focused on
solidarity with partners and allies
we're focused on stronger economic ties
jobs growth and the middle cla and
support for the middle class
but also obviously for standing up for
democracy against authoritarianism and
standing with ukraine every step of the
way
this morning i was able to have an
audience with her majesty queen
elizabeth ii at windsor castle
we
congratulated her obviously on the
platinum jubilee
and
was able to talk a little bit about the
situations we're facing and draw on her
long experience
for having seen much over these past
past decades
um when i met earlier with boris we
discussed stronger security ties
continuing to defend our shared values
continuing to our work together on
advancing free trade and creating more
middle class jobs
and also on climate action where we need
to build a sustainable secure future
i also had a bilateral meeting with mark
rutay where we talked about the enhanced
importance of nato
continuing to work together to fight
disinformation and protecting freedom of
the press and continuing to work
strongly with our friends in the
european union
but of course throughout
the focus is on the people of ukraine
and our solidarity with ukraine are
pushing back against uh the illegal
russian invasion of ukraine uh and uh
standing up for democracies around the
world
foreign
canada uk and the netherlands are close
defense partners
we're working together to mobilize the
global community to step up to support
ukraine and will continue
to defend democracy and the values that
underpin it and continue to make sure
that putin is held accountable
today canada is announcing new sanctions
on 10 individuals complicit in this
unjustified invasion this includes
former and current senior government
officials oligarchs and supporters of
russian leadership the names of these
individuals come from a list compiled by
jailed opposition leader alexei navalny
these sanctions put increased pressure
on russia's leadership including on
putin's inner circle
this is of course in addition to all the
other sanctions we've announced
including our recent announcement on
imposing massive tariffs on russian and
belarusian imports
the work we're doing together is
punishing putin and his enablers where
it hurts most in particular by crippling
their financial systems and sanctioning
their central bank
so far in aid for ukraine canada has
sent about a billion dollars worth of
financial assistance and humanitarian
aid
but we have more to do
so
for today we continue to stand with
ukraine united and strong
we are here today as a close
transatlantic nato allies
throughout history
our countries have always been closely
linked
and in times of crisis in times of war
we stand shoulder to shoulder
and so today as war and violence once
again cast a dark shadow over europe we
are working together
for peace and security on the european
continent
and i'd like to thank prime minister
johnson borth thank you so much for
bringing us together
today at this timely moment
because it has been another weekend of
horrific violence in ukraine
we knew it already but in recent days it
has been confirmed that putin remains
unmoved
we are dealing with an aggressor who
keeps crossing new boundaries
civilians and civilian targets and even
a nuclear power plant have been attacked
recently
and we know now that putin has used
cluster bombs
we can only guess what he plans to do
next
but one thing is certain russia's
aggression must stop
and in our meeting this morning we again
stressed the importance of unity
to all ukrainians we say this
your courage
and your resistance exemplified by
president vladimir zelinsky deserves our
utmost respect
your resolve is our resolve we will
continue to stand by you
in the past few days aid and military
supplies have been sent to ukraine from
the netherlands as well as the uk and
canada
and we will continue to do everything we
can to help canada
the netherlands is prepared to consider
and we are all prepared to consider all
possible sanctions that can help
put pressure on russia
and obviously there's a lot of debate
going on about
energy sanctions and here we move we
should not make a mistake
we have to ensure that they don't
generate unmanageable risks to energy
supplies in european countries and
beyond including ukraine
as has also been stated today by german
chancellor olof schultz and i think
rightly so
so that means that we still need
european companies to continue their
work towards russia
and that is important and of course what
we need to do over time is to make sure
that we reduce dramatically our energy
dependency on russia that's clear
finally i'm pleased that there is a
broad international agreement on the
fact that possible war crimes must be
investigated
we must document everything
that points towards human rights
violations now
so that when the time comes we can
prosecute
and try those responsible
peace and justice must have been out of
violence and injustice
thank you very much mark and thank you
justin let's go now to the media gary
gibbon channel 4.
thank you prime minister um could you
elaborate all perhaps a bit more about
the energy discussions and
where those where they're going the u.s
secretary of state said there are active
discussions
for an oil ban from europe it sounds as
though you don't feel that's the case
prime minister and and you prime
minister
your views are characterized in the
newspapers this morning as saying the
west should have a climate change pass
should we bust through the caps for a
while in order to insulate europe from
russia whether it's going to turn
supplies off or we're going to
walk away from them in europe and one
quick one if i make you specifically
prime minister on refugees
um
whether the numbers are still 50 that
have come to this country or have gone
up a little
it seems like they've only gone up a
little
isn't that embarrassing
thanks well let me let me just uh
before i bring in colleagues on the uh
on the hydrocarbons uh issue uh i think
there are
different dependencies in in different
countries we have to uh we have to be
mindful of of that and uh you can't
simply close down uh use of of oil and
gas uh overnight uh even from from
russia that's that's that's obviously
not something that uh every country
around the world can do
we can go fast in the in the uk other
countries can go fast but there are
there are different dependencies what we
need to do is to make sure that we're
all moving in the same direction and we
all share the same assumptions and that
we accelerate uh that move and i think
that is what uh you're gonna see and
you've heard that from uh from leaders
around the world and actually i see no
inconsistency by the way uh in moving
away uh from dependency on uh on russian
hydrocarbons to moving away from
dependency on our hydrocarbons all
together and uh you know you can see how
uh
this will encourage the world uh to go
gary for uh for for green solutions
wherever possible but clearly there is
going to be a transitional period we're
going to have to look for supply we're
going to have to look for substitute uh
supplies uh from elsewhere and we're
gonna have to do it uh together across
the uh the entire coalition of countries
uh that is now uh condemning uh putin's
actions and on your on your um your
point about um
uh
the the uk's uh
reception of
of of refugees we are absolutely
determined to uh be as generous as we
possibly can and as i speak to you all
we're processing thousands clearly of
applications clearly as the as the
situation has got worse
uh we are going to have to make sure
that we we do even more and the routes
that we have already the family reunion
route offers the prospect of hundreds of
thousands uh coming here uh the the
humanitarian sponsorship group is is
also uncapped and uh we're putting
people out into uh into all the
surrounding countries into into poland
into bulgaria romania as well as into uh
into cali to france uh to make sure that
we receive people who and we help we
help people to come don't forget the uk
uh since 2015 has been the most generous
of with great respect to mark and all
other european colleagues we've been the
most most generous of uh of all european
countries in settling uh vulnerable
people uh we took a large number of of
afghan refugees as you remember under op
uh pitting and uh we will uh and and a
hundred and four thousand uh hong kong
chinese who have applied under asking we
will be very very generous as the people
of this country uh would expect and will
want uh two people fleeing the war in in
ukraine and i know that's going to be
the instinct of the british people but
uh colleagues on the on the on the uh
hydrocarbons the the painful reality is
that we are still very much dependent on
russian gas and russian oil
and if you now would force european
companies to quit doing business with
russia that would have
enormous ramifications
around
europe including ukraine but also around
the world so we have to dramatically
reduce our dependency
on gas and oil from russia that will
take time
a statement earlier today by olive
schultz the chancellor of germany i
think was in the same direction so the
painful reality is there
and that means that
we have to be very clear and make no
mistakes here this is a step-by-step
approach
and that means that we have to make sure
that the energy supplies in this part of
the world again including ukraine but
also in the rest of the world are not
hindered and that will take time
i think what is clear is that
many countries have realized that
continued reliance on
russia's oil and gas is a problem for
the future what we're seeing with
the solidarity and the unity uh not just
of uh countries and democracies across
europe and north america but indeed
countries around the world uh looking at
trying to secure
more
reliable sources of energy particularly
green sources
what we're seeing is a shift in europe
and elsewhere to understand that russia
is no longer a reliable partner what
vladimir putin has broken here
is a trust where for a number of
europeans reflect on it's too bad that
we are so dependent on russian oil but
we're not going to make that mistake
again and they are moving away from it
canada imports negligible amounts of
russian petrochemicals and oil we've
banned that but we are of course
self-sustainable in terms of uh
oil and energy but we will be there to
support as the world moves beyond
russian oil and indeed beyond fossil
fuels to have more renewables in our mix
thanks so much gary a raymond fillion of
tva
surely
what will canada do with regards to its
military spending
right
a number of years ago we put forward a
defense plan that included increasing
our defense spending by 70 percent uh
but we also recognize that the context
is changing rapidly around the world and
we need to make sure that the women and
men who serve in the canadian armed
forces have all the equipment necessary
to be able to stand strongly as we
always have as members of nato we will
continue to look at what more we can do
thanks very much um justin
fleur lansbach from nos
i have a question for prime minister
johnson
last week there was a journalist in
poland that asked you
why do ukrainians have to flee their
homes why are their children taking the
hit in this war while putin's friends
and his inner circle are still living in
london's most beautiful houses
and taking their children to private
schools
i was just wondering has anything
changed since that question was asked
thank you very much fleur yes it
certainly has and i think that you if
you look at
uh what we've done uh just today uh with
the the economic crime bill we're taking
we're taking steps uh to ensure that we
whip aside the veil of of anonymity uh
that that obscures the ownership of the
of the properties that uh that you
describe so you can no longer use a
bogus company uh to conceal your
ownership of a of a property where we
are
making sure that we have new powers to
uh
distrain to take people's uh to take
people's assets uh and we think that
that will have uh we think the whole
package of measures that we're putting
forward today uh will uh have ron ascend
uh in just in just a few days time so uh
we're moving very very fast on that but
i hope that uh you know our viewers and
all of you will recognize that that is
in addition uh to the huge work that the
uk has done together uh with uh with
mark and with justin on the big package
of international sanctions and um if you
look at what we did on uh together on on
swift what we did on the on the uh the
russian central bank uh it uh it's
already had a a profound effect and i
think i'm right in saying that even
today the the russian stock market is is
not opening and uh you know there's not
a testimonial i necessarily seek uh but
i you know i observe that the uh the
russian foreign ministry uh said that
the uk had not been entirely uh helpful
uh in this uh in this regard towards uh
their own uh economic interest and i'm
sure you'll have seen uh what you said
uh and we are going to continue uh to
work with uh colleagues to ensure that
uh we tighten the the vice
around president putin's regime
look what's happening now is that uh he
the president of russia is plainly
doubling down uh he's decided that
he's going to continue with an all-out
onslaught on
centers of habitation in a way that we
think is utterly repugnant
it's clear that we're going to have to
do more and
as friends and partners that's what
that's what we're going to do
uh i think that question was for anybody
else let's go to jason groves from the
the daily mail
um thank you you've all had some success
with your sanctions they're squeezing
russia but also having an impact here
we've seen the gas price treble where
you're seeing petrol passes heading
towards two panzer lisa what would you
say prime minister to
people who desperately want to help but
are worried about that can you give a
commitment now that there is going to be
more help
on the way
mr trudeau can ask is canada ready to
increase its oil and gas output to help
wean mr rutter and others
uh off that russian gas and also you've
seen the queen today how is she we've
not seen it for a while is she fighting
for it
jason look it's a really important
question i think everybody is going to
be uh thinking that you you've ever
already seen what's happened to the
price of oil uh this this this matters
uh which is why i think what mark had to
say uh earlier on about the need to
proceed in uh in steps is is correct uh
and we must
you know do everything we can to protect
uh consumers and the public there are
going to be impacts let's be in no doubt
there are going to be impacts uh but i
think that uh it's the right it's the
right thing to do uh but we've got a and
it's it's the right thing it's
completely the right thing to do to uh
to move away from
russian hydrocarbons from dependence on
russian hydrocarbons but uh we've got to
do it step by step so far the success of
uh of the west has been in the unity uh
that we've shown i think we are all
increasingly united in the view that
we've got to move away now uh from
russian hydrocarbons we've got to do it
together we've got to make sure that we
have substitute and substitute supply
and that's what we're uh we're working
on as well
we will do everything that we can to
ensure that we have uh substitutes and
substitute supply so
one of the things that we're looking at
is the
possibility the uh of
using more of our own hydrocarbons and
you'll have heard already what uh the
business secretary has had to say about
about licenses uh for for uk
uk's own domestic production
that doesn't mean that we are in any way
abandoning our commitment to uh reducing
co2 uh you can you can do that but we've
got to reflect the uh the reality
that
there is a crunch on at the moment we
need to intensify uh our self-reliance
as a transition uh with more
hydrocarbons but what we also need to do
is go for more nuclear and
and much more use of renewable energy
and i'm going to be setting out a an
energy strategy and energy supply
strategy uh for the country in the in
the days ahead so that people have a
sense of how we're going to
meet people's needs over the the the
short medium and and long term
mariaka
sorry justin sorry it's all good um what
we learned over the past couple of years
is that global
challenges
have impacts domestically
covig crisis was a perfect example of
disrupted supply chains that
led to significant inflation challenges
around the world we made a promise to
canadians that we'd have people's backs
and that's exactly what we've been
focused on
the challenge
right now of russia's illegal invasion
of ukraine is having ripple effects
around the world not just uh in energy
prices for canadians and for people in
europe but for people in the global
south as well disruption of the un food
program disruptions uh that are
happening that we are going to have to
adjust to we're going to have to make
sure we are there for each other
and that is the focus that we have
as partners but it's why we've all been
reaching out around the world to talk
with fellow leaders about the challenges
they're facing the challenges their
people are facing because what we are
learning
about russia's unreliability as a
trading partner needs to be remembered
but we also have to work together to
provide substitutes to provide
alternatives and of course we need
to move uh forward to decarbonizing our
economies but we need to do that in a
way that supports people through that
process and we're going to continue
doing that
in regards to her majesty i have
i have the particular privilege of
having known her majesty uh or for about
45 years now uh and i can tell you that
in my conversation
with her this morning she was as
insightful and perspicacious as ever uh
very interested in what's going on asked
me all sorts of questions about canada
and we had a really useful for me anyway
conversation about global events as we
always do
thanks very much justin okay
uh
marika walsh from the from the global
mail
good afternoon thank you um a few
questions for all three of you
uh you're talking about this
humanitarian coalition what exactly is
that what good will it do for the people
of ukraine concretely
and regarding sanctions uh prime
minister trudeau is announcing more
today but we haven't seen it actually
change the behavior of russia in ukraine
so
is enough being done on that and prime
minister johnson particularly for you
you spend more than the 2 target in nato
canada spends well less is that
acceptable to you
so uh
should we have a go at that first how's
it going okay well thank you
uh marika thank you very much look uh
yes it's true we spent about 2.4 percent
now um uh but uh look i i
um i think that canada is a fantastic
ally friend and partner and i'm not
going to make any comment on uh on uh on
canada's approach except to say uh this
that i do think that
the world is clearly changing and i
think that what we can't do uh post uh
the invasion of ukraine is assume that
we can go back to a kind of status quo
ante a kind of new normalization in the
way that we did after uh the invasion of
crimea in 2014 or the the the seizure of
crimea and and and uh
and the donbass area uh we've got to
recognize that things have changed and
that we need a new focus on our
collective security and i think that
that that is that is kind of uh
increasingly understood uh by by
everybody and on your on your first
point about what the humanitarian
coalition uh look i mean the whole world
is now coming together to try to help
avert a total catastrophe in uh in in
ukraine it's already very very grim uh
indeed we're doing everything in our
power uh to prevent it from getting uh
from getting worse
um
and one of the most important things is
to look after people fleeing uh the war
zone and all of us in our in our
different ways are doing a lot as i and
you'll have heard the uh the sums that
we've announced today to uh to help the
immediate vicinity and and what we're
doing to take people i know that both uh
the gentleman
here who are here with me
their countries have a fantastic record
of humanitarian uh help
well
on defense spending we decided early
january when the new team the new
cabinet started to ramp up uh defense
spending
by billions of euros
and that will bring us close to the two
percent uh and probably we need to do
more
particularly given what has happened
over the last two weeks but the
netherlands will spend a lot of extra
money on defense and i think rightly so
the european coalition i think it is
crucial
that this is not only nato european
union working together but that is the
whole world
coming together to
defend the basic values
and the international legal order as it
has been established after the second
world war and which is now being
challenged by one country invading the
second biggest european nation being
ukraine being invaded by the biggest
european nation so this is this is a
huge event and this has huge impact on
the whole world and we have to bring
together africa latin america asia
everyone who wants to be part of
humanity
to be part of such a humanitarian
coalition and
yes i agree with you the sanctions so
far have not had the desired effect they
have a huge effect on russia they are
not against the russians
but against the russian leadership but
of course it will have an effect
uh unavoidably and ultimately also on
individual russians that that we cannot
um prevent
and i think in the longer term it will
have a big impact on russia will also
have an impact on how they will move
forward but you are absolutely right at
the moment in the short term
it has not led to the result that they
stopped the invasion that's true
but that's why we are resolved in being
there for the long term the courage of
ukrainians and standing up
to the russian invaders has inspired and
humbled
us all
and we need to show ourselves as
determined to push back against putin
against the kremlin
as hard as we can and as effectively as
we can
and that's where i mean from the
beginning uh boris and i and a couple of
others were pushing so hard on swift
on the central banks on on the russian
central bank including going after their
ability to draw on their reserves
something that even a week ago we didn't
think
would be in the cards and yet
seeing just how strongly
democracies around the world have stood
and responded i think is a surprise to
putin perhaps a little bit of a surprise
to all of us as well that we actually
can stand
and push back really hard
for the principles that drive us and
quite frankly the
unprecedented display of support of 141
countries at the united nations
supporting this resolution
means that as we move forward this is of
course about ukrainians and ukraine but
it's also about more than that
it's about standing up
for the rules-based order
that has led to unprecedented peace and
stability and growth around the world
over the past many decades
and the pushback that
one like russia like putin specifically
cannot overthrow
those 75 plus years of peace and
stability and still benefit
from the economic largesse and growth
that comes with that and that
firmness is not just
western democracies like us
that is uh something that we've heard in
our conversations all three of us with
partners around the world
who don't have the same kinds of ties to
ukraine but are very very concerned
about the violation of the rule of law
the principle that suddenly might might
be right once again
the principle of territorial integrity
respect for sovereignty the kind of
neo-colonialism that vladimir putin is
trying to impose upon ukrainians
that's not going to fly in the strength
and the resolve
of countries around the world to say no
this is a moment to stand
for democracy
against disinformation misinformation
propaganda
and to stay true to these values that
have led to respect and prosperity
around the world that we continue to
need to fight for including
in many different parts of the world
whether it's afghanistan
or elsewhere as well
thank you thank you thank you
okay excuse me
[Music]
thank you very much uh justin last
question is to yost dauber of financial
duckblood
thank you um
you have all stressed the importance of
unity in the western response to to
russia um but when it comes to energy
sanctions there seems to be
a big difference between your position
and the position of the united states um
with um secretary of state blinking
coming out in favor of an oil ban
and also saying that there are
advanced discussions with the europeans
about this
was
the american secretary of state wrong to
say that there are uh advanced
discussions and um prime minister voter
can you please also elaborate what the
discussions uh you are having in the
european union context are about this
thank you
thanks so let me just just say quickly
that uh no i don't think tony blinken
was wrong in the sense that uh we're all
together uh now moving very very fast
and seeing
the the uh something that perhaps uh
three or four weeks ago we would never
have con considered is is now very much
on the table uh we have to consider how
uh we can all move away uh as fast as
possible uh from dependence reliance on
russian hydrocarbons uh russian oil and
gas and everybody's doing that
everybody's on the same journey uh some
countries will find it uh faster and
easier than others that's all but we're
gonna do it i'm gonna do it together
because and we're gonna work together on
making sure that we all have uh the
substitutes and the supplies that we
that we need
i agree and if
so in that sense it is a
step by step
process and we have to make sure to
deleverage our dependency
on russian gas and russian oil and
whilst acknowledging at the moment that
the dependency is to a certain extent
still there
and
if we would force companies to quit
doing business with russia in that realm
that would have enormous consequences
because it would
basically undermine supply chains the
world over particularly in europe it
would also have an impact on ukraine
itself
and therefore my plea is
to do this diligently
and not overnight
and making sure that we speed up
the programs all over countries to
decarbonize
to green our economies it makes it more
important to do that
okay everybody thank you very much thank
you colleagues uh very much indeed thank
you for your time thank you thank you